ماذا عن اخر التطورات المتعلقه بالقصف
والاوضاع الميدانيه في شمال قطاع غزه
خصوصا واننا كنا شاهدنا قبل قليل صورا
لقصف طال بيت
حانون صحيح القصف الاسرائيلي متواصل على
مدينه غزه وعلى مختلف المناطق في مدينه
غزه لكن يتركز في المناطق الشرقيه
والمناطق التي تتواجد بها قوات الاحتلال
وهناك عدد من العائلات المحاصره في تلك
الاماكن تركز القصف الاسرائيلي ال صباح
اليوم في منطقه حي الشجاعيه وهذه المنطقه
لا يستطيع احد الوصول اليها علما ان هناك
نداءات استغاثه من هذه المنطقه بسبب
محاصره عدد من العائلات في منطقه الشعف
ومنطقه السنفور وصعوبه الوصول اليها
والخروج منها بشكل كبير جدا لكن الان
نداءات الاستغاثه من عائله سالم التي قصف
منزلهم الذي لجوا اليه وهو منزل عائله ابو
رمضان بجانب برج الحصري في منطقه حي
الرمال وقصفت العائله وهناك ما يزيد عن
120 شهيدا واخبرت العائله ان هناك عددا من
الناجين لكن دبابات الاحتلال تتواجد في
محيط ذاك المكان ويصعب انتشال هؤلاء
الشهداء والمصابون الذين هم اسفل الانقاظ
حتى هذه اللحظه على غرار ذلك القصف
الاسرائيلي المدفعي متواصل في المناطق
الشماليه الغربيه لمدينه غزه وهذه المناطق
هي غالبا تتواجد بها قوات الاحتلال منذ ما
يزيد عن 50 يوما وتقصف بشكل مستمر في هذه
المنطقه لا نعرف حتى ايضا ماهيه هذه ال
القصف علما ان عدم معرفه ماهيه القصف هو
انقطاع الاتصالات وانقطاع التواصل ما بين
السكان في مختلف المناطق بسبب تواجد
الاحتلال في منتصف مدينه غزه وهذه المنطقه
التي تفصل ما بين المنطقه الغربيه
والمنطقه الشرقيه وايضا الشماليه
والجنوبيه لكن على شمال قطاع غزه وهذه
المناطق التي تقصف بشكل مستمر ولا يوجد
بها اي مشفى يعمل سوى بعض النقاط الطبيه
ومما يشكل خطرا على حياه الجرحى الذين
اصيبوا باصابات بالغه الخطوره ويؤدي ذلك
الى استشهادهم بشكل مستمر يعني اسماعيل
بعد قيام قوات الاحتلال باقتحام مستشفى
العوده يمكن القول انه لم يعد هناك اي
مستشفى يعمل في مناطق الشمال
تماما قوات الاحتلال لم تقتحم فقط مستشفى
العوده ايضا اقتحمت مستشفى المعمداني
والان الدبابات تتواجد في داخل المستشفى
وتمنع اي احد الاقتراب من تلك المنطقه لا
يعمل سوى مستشفى الشفاء بادنى الامكانات
وادنى الاح وادنى المقومات التي
ايضا اقتحم هذا المستشفى قوات الاحتلال
وعاثت في هذا المستشفى خرابا ودمرت
الاجهزه وفق ما ما اخبرت المصادر الطبيه
الان هذه النقطه فقط تعمل بادنى الامكانات
وفقط اسعافات اوليه لا يوجد اي مستشفى
يعمل بشكل رسمي داخل مدينه داخل منطقه
شمال قطاع غزه سوى فقط نقاط اسعافات اوليه
وتحول ايضا مستشفى الشفاء الى نقطه تس
اوليه وهذه ايضا هي الكارثه الكبرى التي
لحقت بالكوادر الصحيه وايضا عائلات
الكوادر الصحيه هي عائلات نازحه ولا ولا
يمكن للكوادر الصحيه تركع عائلاتهم في ظل
هذا النزوح الكبير من منطقه الى اخرى
اشكرك اسماعيل الغول مراسلنا من مجمع
الشفاء في غزه